Diese Luft, die Natur, die Tiere.
Hier auf der Alp kann sich der gestresste Mensch von heute so richtig erholen.
Vergiss es!
Ich bin froh, dass auch sie ein bisschen stöhnen und sie machen es schon seit eineinhalb Monaten.
Und ich erst einen Tag.
Wir sind vier Monate lang hier.
Das heisst, dass man es sich gut überlegen muss, wie man sich alles einteilt.
Vier Monate lang, sieben Tage die Woche, 14 Stunden arbeiten.
Ich habe Kopfschmerzen, Jetlag und Schlafmangel. Alles.
Das ist meine Geissentaufe früh morgens.
Tip top.
Drei Tage auf der Alp
im Bündnerland anpacken -
das ist "Mona mittendrin:
Auf der Geissalp".
Das Navi hat mich in das hinterste Eck des Val Medel gelotst.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was mich hier erwartet.
Ich bin Mona.
- Hallo. Sara.
Freut mich sehr.
Das ist Aliyah.
- Hallo, Aliyah. Ich bin Mona.
Was macht ihr jetzt gerade?
- Wir waschen die Käsebretter.
Wir sind nämlich auf einer Geissalp.
Und der Name lautet Puzzetta.
Und du bist die Älplerin?
- Ich bin die Sennin.
Sennin.
Unser Team besteht noch aus Paula,
die im Keller gerade Käse schmiert,
und zwei Hirtinnen,
Felicitas und Tabea.
Die sind im Moment
mit den Geissen unterwegs.
Ihr seid also eine Frauenalp?
- Genau, ja.
Komplett, nicht?
Also passe ich hier gut rein.
Davon abgesehen, dass man mich wohl
nicht für viel brauchen kann.
Aber ich bin zumindest eine Frau.
- Schön, dass du hier bist.
Dann hier noch.
Das ist also der Trick? Deswegen
kommen sie am Abend gerne zurück?
Ja.
Die Walliser Geissen sieht man gut,
schwarz-weiss mit langen Haaren.
Sie laufen dort drüben.
Muss man die Geissen treiben
oder kommen sie gerne?
Am Anfang hatten sie Megalust auf
Salz und rannten immer nach Hause.
Aber jetzt gehen sie ganz normal.
Vegni, vegni! Vegni, vegni!
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Kommt!
Ich glaube, ihr müsst etwas zurück.
Sonst kommen sie nicht.
Sie sind heute
so langsam wie noch nie.
(Die erste Hirtin,
die mir entgegen kommt,
ist Felicitas, Aliyahs Mutter.)
Hallo.
- Sie sind kamerascheu.
Ich bin Mona.
- Hallo.
Vegni, vegni! Vegni, vegni!
* Lockrufe *
Vegni, vegni!
* Glockenbimmeln *
Wir haben auch ein Schaf.
Es ist unser eigenes.
Warum ist das hier?
Das hat eine Geiss als Mama.
Keine Ahnung warum, da war etwas.
Es ist einfach dabei.
Das einzige Schaf unter 360 Geissen.
Wir haben uns noch nicht gesehen.
Ich bin Mona.
Tabea.
- Hoi, Tabea.
Wie war dieser Tag für euch?
Das Wetter war sehr schön,
das war cool.
Die Geissen sind weit hochgestiegen,
aber sie waren ruhig.
Ist das jeden Tag unterschiedlich?
Es kommt sehr auf das Wetter an,
manchmal auch darauf,
wie wir drauf sind.
Heute nahmen wir eine andere Route
als in den letzten Tagen.
Sie müssen sich dann neu gewöhnen.
Hast du alle dabei?
- Das werden wir beim Melken sehen.
Ich hoffe es.
* Schwungvolle Akkordeonmusik *
(363 Geissen
sind auf der Alp Puzzetta.)
(Mehr als die Hälfte davon
wird zweimal am Tag gemolken.)
(Diese muss man jetzt aussortieren.)
(Studentin Paula ist Zusennin.)
(Sie hilft
im ersten Monat der Alpsaison,
dann ist es hier
am anstrengendsten.)
Paula hat megaviele blaue Flecken.
Was? Megaviele blaue Flecken?
Wirklich?
Na ja, jetzt geht es langsam.
Woher stammen die?
Sie boxen manchmal mit den Hörnern.
An den Beinen entstehen die Flecken,
wenn ein Gedränge herrscht
und zwei Geissen kämpfen
und ich im Weg stehe.
Doch, ich freue mich!
Nein!
(Ich versuche,
beim Sortieren zu helfen.)
(Mit Kühen habe ich etwas Erfahrung,
aber mit Geissen überhaupt nicht.)
Schau mal ... Nein.
Man kann doch nicht einfach reissen.
(Aliyah zeigt mir, wie es geht.)
(Sie ist zehn und bereits
zum siebten Mal auf der Alp.)
* Verspielte Musik *
Jetzt geh schon!
(Im Geissen-Nahkampf
habe ich mir die ersten
blauen Flecken schon gesichert.)
* Seufzen *
Ich bin schon total ruiniert.
Ich getraue mich noch nicht ganz,
richtig zuzupacken.
Ich werde meine Scheu
bald ablegen müssen,
sonst machen die mich platt.
Wann man hier nicht dagegenhält,
ist man nach zwei Tagen ...
(Am Anfang des Sommers kommen jeden
Tag 250 l Geissenmilch zusammen,
die auf Puzzetta
zu Alpkäse verarbeitet werden.)
* Verspielte Musik *
(Hier haben alle viel Alperfahrung,
aber sie sind zum ersten Mal
ein reines Frauenteam.)
(Hirtin Felicitas arbeitet sonst
als Körpertherapeutin in Graz.)
(Hirtin Tabea
ist Projektleiterin im Val Medel.)
(Paula ist Studentin.)
(Und Sennin Sara arbeitet
als Produktdesignerin in Zürich.)
Seit wann seid ihr auf den Beinen?
Seit 5 Uhr?
- 5 Uhr, ja.
Seit 5 Uhr.
Und der Tag ist noch nicht vorbei.
Um 21.30 Uhr ist Feierabend,
aber dann müssen wir noch essen.
Aha?
Dann sind wir fertig mit Arbeiten.
- Aha? Okay.
Was für ein Typ muss man sein,
um auf einer Alp zu arbeiten?
Ich glaube, es braucht ...
* Lachen *
... viel Ausdauer.
Oder wie nennt man das? Arbeits-
technisch braucht es Ausdauer.
Es ist aber doch schön,
weil man sehr viele Freiheiten hat.
Wir können uns den Tag einteilen,
so wie es am besten funktioniert.
Ihr gebt also den Ton an
und sagt, wie was gemacht wird?
Oder nicht?
- Die Geissen geben den Ton an.
Das Wetter gibt den Ton an.
Und schon auch das, was rauskommen
soll. Der Käse soll ja gut sein.
Es sind extrem hohe Ansprüche.
Es soll den Geissen gut gehen,
sie sollen zu genug Futter kommen.
Der Käse soll super werden.
Auf allen Ebenen
sind die Ansprüche sehr hoch.
Wir sind für vier Monate hier.
Wie schafft man es sich,
sich so einzuteilen?
Das muss man auch können.
Man muss sich trotz allem
einteilen können, denn ...
Es geht darum,
diese vier Monate durchzuhalten.
Es soll einem dabei
ja auch gut gehen.
(Nach dem Melken gehen die Geissen
noch mal auf die Weide.)
(Diesen Aufwand
betreibt man nicht auf jeder Alp.)
(Aber ihnen sei wichtig,
dass die Geissen
auch am Abend
bestes Futter bekommen.)
Vegni!
Vegni, vegni, vegni!
Vegni, vegni!
(Tabea und die anderen Frauen
tragen die Verantwortung
für die Geissen
von 30 verschiedenen Bauern.)
Gut, dort kannst du anhalten.
Wie verschaffst du dir
Autorität bei den Geissen?
Es ist mehr Zusammenarbeit
und weniger klare Autorität.
Es ist auch Vertrauenssache.
Wir sprechen oft darüber.
Vertraut man den Geissen oder nicht?
Machen sie zu viel Unsinn?
Aber gleichzeitig laufen sie dir
am Morgen auch hinterher.
Sie vertrauen dir, dass du sie
an einen guten Futterplatz führst.
Deshalb ist es Zusammenarbeit.
Nicht klare Autorität.
(Es geht
steile Alpenrosenhänge hinauf.)
(Einen Pfad gibt es nicht.)
* Gemächliche Musik *
(Um 21.30 Uhr
sind wir bei der Nachtweide.)
(Die Geissen bleiben bis zum Morgen
in dieser Umzäunung.)
Vegni, vegni, vegni, vegni!
Das mögt ihr, wie?
Es ist noch schwierig,
wenn man selbst relativ klein ist.
Schau mal!
Nicht wahr?
So.
Jetzt ist Ende der Vorstellung,
sonst musst du
im Circus Knie arbeiten.
Haben wir alle?
Wir können beim Runtergehen
kontrollieren.
Hier ist ein Draht.
Dann kannst du es festmachen.
Irgendwo rechts oder links.
- Am Abend bleiben sie gut zusammen.
(Feierabend vor 22 Uhr gibt es
auf der Alp Puzzetta selten.)
(Alle) Guten Appetit.
(Die Nacht ist kurz.)
(Um 5 Uhr stehen alle wieder auf.)
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
* Ruhige Klänge *
Vegni! Vegni!
* Glockenbimmeln *
Der erste Preis für dich.
Komm! Vegni, vegni, vegni!
(Wenn die Geissen
von der Nachtweide zurück sind,
heisst es wieder
sortieren und melken.)
(Dafür brauchen wir etwa 2 Std.)
Ich bin froh, dass sie auch stöhnen.
Denn sie machen es schon
seit eineinhalb Monaten
und ich erst seit einem Tag.
(Den ersten Kaffee trinkt man
auf der Alp im Stall draussen.)
Jetzt gibt's Gauraccino.
(Und was für einen!
Einen Gauraccino.)
(Gaura heisst Geiss auf Romanisch.)
Gauraccino.
(Er kommt frisch ab Tier
und mit perfekten Schäumchen.)
Das ist meine Geissen-Taufe
am frühen Morgen.
Tipptopp.
(Der Tag erwacht langsam
im Val Medel.)
(Und auch für andere Alpbewohner
ist es Zeit fürs Frühstück.)
Hier musst du
ein bisschen aufpassen.
Einfach reinschütten,
ein bisschen verteilen.
Die zwölf Ferkel.
(Zwölf Ferkel -
vorgestern wurden sie geboren.)
(Aufbruch.)
Zili, komm her, zu mir!
Ziel ist die Ebene,
die man jetzt nicht sieht.
Okay.
Sie können auch
dort zu den Felsen hochziehen.
Aber das machen sie
vielleicht nicht.
Vegni, vegni!
(Den ganzen Tag werden wir
mit den Geissen unterwegs sein.)
(Es geht hoch hinauf, immer auf
der Suche nach dem besten Futter.)
Gehen wir!
Zili!
(Zusammen mit Felicitas
und Hirtenhündin Zili
mache ich das Schlusslicht.)
(Auf der Alp feuert Sara
den Ofen für den Kessel ein.)
(Sie kümmert sich mit Paula
um das Käsen.)
(Die vier Frauen
machen hier oben vieles allein.)
(Das ist nur dank
der Alpgenossenschaft möglich,
die sie anstellt und unterstützt,
z.B. beim Unterhalt der Alp.)
(Mit 363 eigenwilligen Geissen
unterwegs zu sein
ist eine logistische
Meisterleistung.)
(Felicitas muss mit Hirtenhündin
Zili dafür sorgen,
dass alle zusammenbleiben.)
Heute sind sie schneller.
Hm?
- Heute sind sie schneller.
Zili, warte. Zili!
Schau, die sind schon da oben.
Was? Okay.
- Zili, zu mir! Zu mir!
Der erste Ausbruchsversuch
wurde erfolgreich abgewehrt.
Wie wichtig ist der Hund
für deine Arbeit?
Es ist die doppelte Belastung.
Ohne Hund?
-Ja.
Man muss mehr laufen
und mehr schreien.
Der Hund hat eine Schnelligkeit,
vor der die Geissen Respekt haben.
Sie müssen checken: Wir sind
in einer Herde und gehen gemeinsam.
(Geissen sind wirklich eigensinnig.)
(Die einen büxen aus,
die anderen bleiben einfach stehen.)
Diese vier lassen wir hier.
- Die lassen wir hier?
Ja, die kommen
nicht so gut über das Wasser.
Die bleiben hier.
Bleibt ihr hier?
Wir holen euch wieder ab,
wenn wir zurückkommen.
Tipptopp.
* Helle Hackbrettklänge *
Super.
(Viel weiter oben sorgt Tabea
mit ihrer Hündin Spax dafür,
dass die vordersten Geissen
einen guten Weg einschlagen.)
(Die Hirtinnen müssen aufpassen,
dass die Herde
nicht in unwegsames Gelände gerät,
von wo sie sie
nicht rausholen können.)
(Die Devise ist:
so wenig eingreifen wie möglich.)
(Je entspannter die Tiere sind,
desto besser fressen sie.)
Schau, wie schön!
Oh!
Hallo.
Das ist ein historischer Moment.
Schön, wie sie dort hochziehen.
Das ist also perfekt?
Es ist aufregend. Heute gehen sie
zum ersten Mal so weit hinauf.
Wenn sie dort hinaufgehen,
muss auch jemand von uns
dort hinaufgehen.
Aber trotzdem
seid ihr total begeistert?
Meistens fluche ich erst mal:
"Mann, wieso?"
Aber dann keuche ich hinauf,
und wenn ich oben stehe, finde ich:
"Vielen Dank."
- "Schön!"
Es ist ...
... positiv und negativ.
Wenn ich das sehe, verstehe ich,
warum sehr viele Menschen Sehnsucht
nach einem solchen Leben haben.
Aber das ist ja nur
ein Teil der Wahrheit.
Ich glaube ...
Diese schönen Momente
gibt es jeden Tag.
Aber auch die anstrengenden Momente
Ihr bezahlt einen Preis
für dieses Leben.
Welcher Preis ist das?
Vier Monate lang sieben Tage
die Woche 14 Std. arbeiten.
Immer voll dran.
Man verzichtet auch auf vieles.
Warum ist es trotzdem okay?
Man kriegt einen anderen Luxus.
Das glaube ich.
Man hat Weitsicht, man ist draussen.
Wenn man das schätzt,
ist das sehr viel.
Für mich bedeutet diese Zeit:
Ich habe den Luxus,
hier leben zu dürfen.
Für mich ist es auch
die Intensität hier oben.
Ein Festival mit vielen Leuten
und lauter Musik ist auch intensiv,
aber für mich ist das hier
noch viel schöner.
Dieser Moment ist für mich, für uns.
Und er ist viel wertvoller.
In unserer Gesellschaft
heisst es ja oft:
"Was machst du aus deinem Leben?
Was wirst du?"
Ich muss auf mein Herz hören:
Wo zieht es mich hin?
Was macht mich wirklich zufrieden?
Welche Arbeit
mache ich gerne und von Herzen?
Dieser Arbeit soll man nachgehen.
Wenn man dieser Leidenschaft
nachgeht, geht es gut.
Wenn man etwas macht
wegen des Status oder ...
... weil man sich
verpflichtet fühlt,
dann geht es nicht gut.
Jedenfalls nicht für mich.
(Ohne Leidenschaft
wäre dieser Job nicht zu machen.)
(Und schon geht es weiter.)
Gut, bis später.
(Wir müssen
die Geissen zurückholen.)
Ich sehe sie dort oben.
Zumindest drei von 360.
Solange sie dort oben sind,
ist alles okay?
Es ist okay.
Aber sie sind jetzt
ziemlich verteilt.
Die grosse Gruppe ist dort unten.
Einige fressen oben in der Flanke.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir die Gruppen
sehen und alle runterbringen.
Viel Erfolg.
- Danke.
(Auch wenn es anstrengender ist,
die Hirtinnen lassen die Geissen
hoch hinaufsteigen.)
(Eine Geissalp zu betreiben,
ist aufwendig.)
(Eine Kuh
würde nie in solches Gelände gehen.)
Wie lief es?
Tipptopp.
Das ist eines dieser Bilder,
die glücklich machen.
Es ist megaschön.
Wir sind hier gut versammelt
für den Heimweg.
Sie können runterziehen.
Das ist das Gute an dieser Ebene.
Der Platz ist so schön.
(Die Idylle trügt aber.)
(Es ist schwierig,
die traditionelle Art der Alp-
wirtschaft rentabel zu betreiben.)
(Ob solche Alpen
mit den Direktzahlungen
und dem tiefen Preis für Geisskäse
überhaupt noch
bewirtschaftet werden können,
fragen sich auch die Älplerinnen.)
(Zurück auf Puzzetta merken wir:
Die Geissen, die wir beim Bach
zurückgelassen haben, fehlen.)
Entweder haben sie sich
unter die anderen gemischt,
weil sie schon
auf dem Rückweg waren.
Oder sie sind uns nachgezogen
und sind jetzt auf dem Boden,
wo wir waren.
Ich suche sie noch mal.
Wenn ich sie am Berg finde,
müssen wir noch mal hoch.
* Glockenbimmeln,
Lärm der Melkmaschine *
(Beim Melken stellt sich heraus,
dass nicht nur
die zurückgelassenen Geissen fehlen,
sondern noch ein paar mehr.)
(Die Stimmung bei den Hirtinnen
ist angespannt.)
Wenn man am Abend
nicht alle hier hat, nervt das.
Mega.
Schon wegen der zwei,
die wir stehen gelassen hatten,
war ich genervt.
Also nicht nur,
weil ihr noch mal losziehen müsst,
sondern weil ihr ...
- Wir haben es nicht geschafft.
Challenge not finished.
Ja.
(Sie müssen sofort reagieren,
bevor es dunkel wird.)
(Tabea geht los, ohne zu wissen,
wie lange sie unterwegs sein wird.)
(Im schlimmsten Fall
dauert es noch mal 5 Std.)
Während Tabea die Geissen sucht
und die anderen auf die Weide gehen,
muss ja jemand
das Abendessen kochen.
Und es gibt Gitzi.
Schau mal!
Das Gitzi Hermann köchelt.
(Vom Hang oben
kommen gute Nachrichten.)
Hast du sie auch gesehen?
Ja.
Was hat sie gesagt? Wo sind sie?
Sie sind jetzt
da oben bei der Hütte.
Hat sie gesagt, welche dabei sind?
Die beiden, die gefehlt haben,
sind dabei.
Super, die zurückgelassenen.
Genau. Und auch noch andere.
Dort kommen sie.
Tabea musste
gar nicht so weit laufen.
Sie hatte schon Angst,
dass sie ganz hinaufgehen muss.
* Gemächliche Musik *
(Nach knapp 2 Std. ist Tabea
mit den Ausreissern zurück.)
Ich bin froh,
dass sie schon so weit unten waren.
Super, dass du sie
so schnell gefunden hast.
Sie kamen schon selbst runter.
Der Fehler war wohl:
Das ist die Gruppe,
die als letzte nach oben ging,
also haben sie
den Anschluss verpasst.
Auf die harte Tour.
Das hat dich total genervt.
- Ich hatte überhaupt keine Lust.
(Zum Glück doch noch:
Mission completed.)
Ich hoffe, es ist okay.
Für das Gitzi
lege ich meine Hand nicht ins Feuer.
Es hat jetzt 1 Std. geköchelt.
Wenn es jetzt nicht durch ist,
dann wird das nichts mehr.
Guten Appetit.
- (Alle) Guten Appetit.
(Heute muss ich nur ein Schäfchen
zählen und schon schlafe ich.)
* Sanfte Musik *
Kopfschmerzen und ...
* Sie lacht. *
... Jetlag und Schlafmangel
und alles.
Es ist ...
Bis jetzt dachte ich immer,
ich hätte in der RS
richtigen Schlafmangel erlebt,
aber das hier
ist noch mal etwas anderes.
Ich bin schon nach drei Tagen
ziemlich durch.
Kommt!
(Es ist ein Knochenjob
hier oben auf der Alp.)
(Vier Monate durcharbeiten
ohne Wochenende,
14 Std. pro Tag,
für einen Stundenlohn von 9.50 Fr.)
(Und dennoch
ist es auch das grosse Glück.)
* Sie singen zur Musik. *
# Und wenn du dann am Boden bist,
weisst du, wo du hingehörst.
# Wenn du ganz alleine bist,
weisst du, was du warst.
* Glockenbimmeln *
(Während die Geissen
auf die Weide ziehen,
zeigt mir Sennin Sara
das Gold im Keller von Puzzetta.)
(Den Käse.)
Ist das das Ergebnis dieses Jahres
oder auch schon von letztem Jahr?
Nein,
das ist das Ergebnis eines Monats.
Ein Monat? So viel!
Ja, es sind ...
Heute haben wir mit 500 l gekäst.
Das ergibt 50 kg.
Und das sind die jüngsten?
- Genau.
Und du schreibst sie mit Datum an?
Ja, das eine ist die Alpnummer,
die wir oben drauf kleben.
Und dann kommt noch das Datum drauf.
Welche Beziehung
hast du zu diesem Käse?
Du denkst so oft daran,
bist immer hier.
Es ist ...
Es ist eine starke Bindung.
Dieser Moment,
wenn man ihn übergeben kann,
wenn man Rückmeldung bekommt -
das ganze Team -
das ist sehr viel wert.
Es funktioniert,
die Besitzer freuen sich.
Diesen Moment braucht es
nach all dieser Arbeit.
Man kriegt im besten Fall
gute Rückmeldungen.
Was mir besonders gefällt,
ist die Intensität des Ganzen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
nahe dran zu sein.
Und das gibt mir sehr viel zurück.
Aber es kostet ja auch viel.
Du musst zwei Leben
unter einen Hut bringen.
Du bist Produktdesignerin
in Zürich, im Sommer bist du hier.
Das ist nicht einfach.
Ich merke, dass es
immer etwas schwieriger wird.
Oder einfach ...
Das Ganze wird zu einer Identität,
man arbeitet in diesem Team.
Ihr lebt voll für diese Sache.
Wir gehen
viele Dinge im Leben anders an.
Und wenn es sich von einem
auf den anderen Tag wieder ändert,
ist das ...
.. ein grosser Wechsel.
Jetzt kommt dieses hier?
Mann, sind die schwer!
Es dauert etwas,
bis man das Gefühl dafür hat.
Ja, ich habe etwas Angst.
Aber auch hier merkt man,
wie fit ihr sein müsst.
Ich meine körperlich.
Ja, im Keller
ist es auch anstrengend.
(Wo ist das echte Leben? Unten
in der Stadt oder oben auf der Alp?)
(Nach diesen drei Tagen auf der Alp
Puzzetta frage ich mich das auch.)
Rennt Tabea voraus?
* Jauchzen *
Willst du später
auch mal Alphirtin werden?
Ja, oder Bäuerin.
(Hier oben
findet man keine Alpenidylle,
aber eine Intensität
wie kaum sonst wo.)
Diese Kraft und Geborgenheit ist
hier in dieser Bergnatur vorhanden.
Die haben wir jeden Tag.
Danach kommt ja wieder
das andere Leben.
Ihr wechselt von dieser Welt
in eine völlig andere.
Geht das gut?
Das ist eine Challenge.
Es ist eine Challenge,
wieder zu wechseln.
Wird man hier oben
auch etwas seltsam? Oder anders?
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Es macht etwas mit einem, wenn man
auch nur drei Tage dabei ist.
Ja.
Dieses Distanz, die man plötzlich
zu allem anderen hat,
es wirkt sehr unwirklich.
Aber es kann schwierig sein,
wenn man ins normale,
ins andere Leben wechseln muss.
Im Unterland ist man mit
ganz anderen Problemen beschäftigt.
Ja.
Und man kann Menschen,
die einem wichtig sind,
vielleicht nicht
auf diese Reise mitnehmen.
Von jeder Reise
kommt man verändert zurück.
Sich dann wieder zu finden, ist ...
... auch wieder Arbeit.
Das ist wieder eine neues Thema.
Man muss sich wieder kennenlernen.
Und wenn man
auf der Alp lebt und arbeitet,
dann lebt und arbeitet man
voll hier.
Voll leben zu können,
das ist hier einzigartig.
Ihr habt mir
auch etwas weitergegeben,
nämlich den Einblick
in eine unbekannte Welt.
Gern geschehen.
Gibt's noch Kaffee?
(Drei Tage
auf der Geissalp Puzzetta.)
(Einfach voll leben zu können -
das nehme ich mit.)
Mona mittendrin auf der Geissalp.
Ich habe neue Freunde gefunden.
Wenn ihr Fragen oder Anregungen habt, dann schreibt sie mir in die Kommentarspalte.
Mehr DOK-Filme findet ihr hier.
Am besten abonniert ihr unseren DOK-YouTube-Kanal und aktiviert die Glocke.
So bleibt ihr auf dem Laufenden.
Danke für euer Interesse.